hace tan solo tres años era un valle
aislado del mundo moderno a 700
kilómetros de la capital en las
estribaciones del Himalaya la ciudad de
keylong está desde hace poco conectada a
internet algo que le ha cambiado la vida
a sus 1.200 habitantes tal es el caso de
allá y fumar un estudiante de
informática se dirige con frecuencia a
este ciber café el único que dispone de
banda ancha en la ciudad para todos sus
trámites administrativos
que la declaración está casi lista y
pídale que inicie el procedimiento de
verificación
es sencillo antes de la apertura de este
lugar
para todos los trámites debíamos salir
del pueblo
e ir a la primera gran ciudad del
Distrito que se encuentra a 150
kilómetros de aquí
Ellos nos tomaba entre 9 y 10 horas de
carretera
solicitud de pasaporte licencia de
conducción o declaraciones de impuestos
ya no es necesario desplazarse
460.000 centros como este existen a lo
largo del país hace parte del programa
India digital una iniciativa del
gobierno indio que pretende desenclavar
las zonas más alejadas del país poco a
poco han ido desplegando internet
también en las casas así como antenas 3g
y 4G un proyecto ambicioso con un
presupuesto inmenso el año pasado fueron
destinados 850 millones de euros el
objetivo de las autoridades que la vida
cotidiana de los indios se vuelque a la
era digital desde las transacciones
financieras hasta las citas médicas
Esperamos que de aquí a cuatro o cinco
años todos nuestros servicios hayan sido
digitalizados los ciudadanos ya no
necesitarán perder el tiempo buscando
Cómo hacer tal o tal trámite todo será
realizado por internet el 48% de la
población contaría con internet en este
momento es decir unos 650 millones de
indios internet se volvió una
herramienta usada por miles de
ciudadanos que se volvieron de la noche
a la mañana creadores de contenidos o
influenciadores según un estudio de
Oxford economics en el 2020 4000 canales
de YouTube indios habrían superado el
millón de suscriptores una cifra en
constante evolución a 300 kilómetros de
Nueva Delhi en el estado rural de
aryanancing es uno de los primeros que
se lanzó a hacer videos destinados a los
granjeros del país no dudes en tomar
planos amplios
amigos hablemos de una planta que puede
alimentar su ganado y reducirá
drásticamente sus costos hijo de
agricultor abandonó su trabajo en la
ciudad en el 2017 para lanzar su propio
canal que cuenta actualmente con más de
5 millones de suscriptores
noté antes de lanzarme que había muchos
videos tutoriales que hablaban de
actualidad de cómo declarar impuestos o
sobre carros en India pero no había nada
sobre agricultura a los granjeros indios
les gustan estos vídeos porque les damos
consejos para ser más rentables por
ejemplo y solo internet permite eso
Gracias a internet pueden vernos
escucharnos desde su granja Al otro lado
del país
el menú técnicas agrícolas promoción de
productos o encuentros con otros
granjeros entre los contenidos
patrocinados y la cantidad de vistas
darshan logran monetizar sus videos y
multiplicar por 3 sus ingresos es una
situación gana gana para todo el mundo
nuestros espectadores pueden acceder a
contenidos gratuitos en línea y nosotros
los realizadores recibimos un pago de
YouTube o Google en función de la
cantidad de visitas que yo varía todos
los meses por supuesto Pero puede
generarnos entre mil y 6000 euros
mensuales
pero la revolución digital también tiene
límites en la India el país es uno de
los más golpeados por falsas
informaciones que circulan en las redes
sociales sin contar con la censura que
se multiplicó desde la llegada al poder
en el 2014 del partido nacionalista
hindú del Primer Ministro narendra móvil
desde el 2018 el país figura en el podio
de la clasificación de los gobiernos que
bloquean deliberadamente a internet
tan solo durante estos dos últimos años
el gobierno vendió ha bloqueado el
acceso a 15.000 páginas de internet y
siempre han sido realizado de manera
opaca porque usted nunca tiene la
posibilidad de ser escuchado por el
gobierno u otra corte para reclamar no
recibe ningún correo que le explique por
qué fue víctima de censura de un día
para otro sutrino o su estatus de
Facebook con su página web en su canal
de YouTube son suprimidos y usted nunca
sabrá por qué
una censura que tiene un costo tan solo
en el 2020 estos bloqueos de internet Le
habrían hecho perder a la economía 3.000
millones de euros según un estudio
independiente